on est dans l'abomination très
franchement ce jeune garçon c'était son
rêve il est fan de Marseille il va au
stade il y a des gens qui le repèrent
dans une loge où il est au-dessus trois
ou quatre personnes qui foncent dans la
loge un qui tape son père devant lui bah
c'est pas des gens je le sais des
sauvages oui enfin des gens qui étaient
présents pas de supporters d'Ajaccio
parce que le club va très bien
réagiation a donné les images de
vidéosurveillance le président a réagi
parfaitement etc mais ces gens sont
abominables j'espère qu'ils seront
condamnés ce jeune de 8 ans qui a un
grave cancer du cerveau il va être
traumatisé toute sa vie il y a de quoi
Cyril non mais la franchement on est
dans l'inhumanité on est au-delà de ce
qui est supportable
le procureur de la République est
d'Ajaccio s'est exprimé aussi ce matin
pendant une fesses sont grave et
nécessiteront effectivement qu'on puisse
apporter à la famille et c'est bien
légitime l'ensemble des éléments qui
permettront d'asseoir une poursuite
sachant que l'objectif du parquet dans
ce dossier est d'aller vite pour que on
puisse sanctionner à la juste mesure le
comportement de ces supporters sachant
que l'objectif aussi principal et de
viser la peine complémentaire
d'interdiction de participer ensuite à
d'autres manifestations sportives
l'enquête a été enclenchée sur
initiative du commissariat d'Ajaccio sur
mes instructions et que encore une fois
même si le temps judiciaire peut
paraître long nous espérons pouvoir
obtenir rapidement des développements au
cours de la semaine concernant
l'identification des quelques auteurs
qui ont été à l'origine de ces violences
alors faudrait qu'on allait très
fermement violence aggravée avec
circonstances aggravantes parce que
c'est dans une enceinte sportive ça peut
être de 5 à 16 ans de prison Cyril là il
faut que la justice tranche aille très
loin même le président Macron s'est
exprimé ça choque la France entière on
parle même plus d'un spectacle sportif
on parle d'une agression d'une famille
avec un jeune malade je suis révolté je
suis révolté j'espère que ces gens iront
de longues années en prison très
franchement alors il y a une réaction
qui a fait énormément réagir c'est un
supporter regardez qui dit que selon lui
il n'y a pas eu agression ça fait
polémique il dit que Kenzo n'a pas été
agressé il reproche à son papa d'avoir
montré son maillot de l'OM regarde elles
sont sur le petit
bousculer dans un mouvement de
fulleterre
a déjà changé trois fois
de vertu le maillot et tout au dessus
des supporters même si c'est condamnable
et tout ce qui s'est passé il n'avait
pas le faire surtout dans le contexte du
match quand on a un gosse malade de 8
ans dans un contexte comme ça on se
tient un peu plus à carreaux et on évite
de faire le mariole c'est tout le mental
c'est pas possible on peut pas dire
quand on a un enfant malade on se tient
à carreau le principe même d'un match de
foot c'est deux équipes adverses qui
s'affrontent donc par définition il y a
des gens qui auront le maillot d'une
équipe et des gens qui auront le maillot
d'une autre équipe si on considère à ce
moment-là que porter un maillot c'est
une c'est une provocation on marche
enfin on devient fou c'est c'est Inaudi
parce que vient de dire ce monsieur
inaudible c'est honteux ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'en fait ils étaient dans
une loge un peu au dessus et donc les
supporters en dessous ont vu le maillot
de l'OM ils ont montré du doigt le petit
garçon le pauvre a cru qu'on leur
faisait coucou il a fait coucou et eux
ont pris ça pour une provocation et sont
montés
à leur rencontre pour dire que c'était
un petit enfant malade ils ont continué
à monter et ils ont agressé le père et
le fils et ont brûlé enfin pris le
maillot du père et ils l'ont brûlé
ensuite c'est vraiment mais c'est
aucune excuse ne tient aucune excuse
rien alors on va dire pourquoi il met un
maillot de Marseille à Ajaccio bah il a
le droit pourquoi il le Monte bah il a
le droit rien tous les corps euh bien
sûr ont été choqués parce qu'ils bravo
euh oui
il y a personne
le club exemplaire le club d'Ajaccio
tous les corps sont mis des messages
pour dire que c'était absolument vous
avez raison donc bravo eux aussi oui
mais la maman reçoit quand même des des
réseaux des menaces sur les réseaux
sociaux en disant qu'elle salit l'image
de l'accord c'est que c'était une
provocation il y a encore une suite dans
le milieu du foot dans le milieu du foot
il y a quand même une violence non mais
je ne dormais pas mais en tout cas il y
a une violence générale qui devient
insupportable on a l'impression que
année après année il y a toujours des
débordements
lui ont permis en quelque sorte de de
réaliser son rêve en se mettant à ses
côtés donc ça c'est très bien il y a une
grande solidarité au contraire du milieu
du foot face à cette attaque indigne moi
je trouve regarder la photo elle est
magnifique je parle pas des joueurs
ce que j'ai dit ça ne concerne pas ni
les joueurs ni les fédérations ça
concerne les supporters bah tu vois ce
que je dis c'est les supporters le
problème le maire d'Ajaccio avait voulu
faire avait demandé à ce qu'on annule
cette cette ce match parce que c'était à
haut risque la préfecture a pris la
décision de Garges Olympiques qui vont
arriver là il y a les jeux
c'est bien de dire tous les soirs parce
qu'on voit elle dit Géraldine non
sauvagement de la société mais non mais
parce que non mais parce que moi
pour rigoler et tous les soirs on voit
des trucs tous les soirs on voit des
trucs de plus en plus
je vais dire pour une fois tous les
soirs on voit des trucs de ouf de morte
après trois semaines ah je savais pas
j'étais pas là mais tu étais où tu étais
où il y a 3 semaines tu étais où faut
que ici on dise
en attendant
ils sont tout le temps consternés alors
c'est les hommes politiques ça lui plaît
pas là ils sont consternés
[Musique]
à Twitter bravo c'est dramatique ce qui
se passe c'est la raison et on va
chercher on va jamais chercher les
coupables et bien on va jamais chercher
les parents l'éducation aussi aller
chercher les mots
je suis d'accord à 100% avec toi je suis
d'accord à 100 % avec toi je pense que
c'est pas d'accord ici moi je suis pas
d'accord à 100% avec toi